This episode is supported by Hims
Your body is cool and all, but have you ever wondered how much
is it all worth? Let's start with selling your body
one piece at a time. Sperm? You can make $35
to $135 a shot, with some banks paying donors
$1500 for a one-year commitment,
the criteria being you are healthy, tall, young, and educated.
The price for an egg, however, is much
greater at $10 000 and is likely
due to the more invasive 20-minute procedure
to retrieve eggs that can put you at a risk of infection or even
endometriosis. The protein rich part of your blood
aka plasma can be worth $50
However some of the wealthy and aging among us are paying
$8 000 a session to be infused with young blood.
Though evidence is in its early stages, the "fountain
of youth"/"young blood" hypothesis
comes from research at Stanford University where old mice
injected with plasma from umbilical cords of newborn
human babies improved the old mice's performance
on memory tests. Weird. The price of
an organ transplant can be extremely expensive with more than
116 000 Americans waiting to receive
a transplant. A kidney transplant is over $400 000
while a heart can be $1.4M.
That is, however, the cost of the transplant surgery
and not how much you would make selling your organs.
Though illegal in the US and most other nations, the organ
black market does exist. Based on reports by the World Health Organization,
a kidney in India can go for
$20 000; in China, $40 000;
but in Israel, you can make as much as $160 000
Not willing to part with,
well, a part of you? Try selling your hair! A real
wig can cost $800 to $3 000
It's clear that some body parts are worth a lot, but some people
have really put a price tag on their parts
Sources state that Rihanna's legs are insured for
$1 000 000, but that's nothing compared to Cristiano
Ronaldo, whose legs are $144 million.
Then there are the services your body provides. Right now,
you're breathing. You exhale 11 000L a day
and that means you can blow up the tires for about
275 cars. Your sneeze
has a wind speed of 4.5 meters per second
which is enough wind to power a small electric wind turbine.
Your cough is even more powerful at 22.4 meters per second
and could power a utility scale windmill.
Your farts? If your diet is rich in beans, you can
produce 68 mL of carbon dioxide in a single day.
If you store these (we won't ask you why)
but if you did, in 40 years you would have an approximate
metric ton of CO2. That's a lot
of gas, but it would only be worth $220.
Meanwhile, your brain can store 100 tb
of information. The retail value of a hard drive that big
is upwards to $2 500.
Then, there are elements that make up you. Though we're made
mostly of oxygen, carbon, and hydrogen, there are some
very valuable trace elements that contribute to your design like
copper, gold, and even uranium. However,
if you added this all up, your elemental dollar amount
is close to... one dollar.
A huge thank you to Hims for sponsoring today's video and giving all
of our viewers a month's trial to their comprehensive hair kit for only $5.
Hims is a brand that offers men high quality medical products
for the things that we sometimes don't talk about
like sexual well-being, hair loss or acne
But actually 26% of people who experience erectile dysfunction are
under the age of 40.
Your privacy is taken completely seriously and they have really
affordable deals on medical great products, because they use the
generic equivalent instead of the name brand.
They use personalized recommendations for prescription and
non-prescription products with advice from real doctors.
All you have to do is head to forhims.com/asaphair to get a virtual
visit with a doctor and a month trial of the comprehensive hair kit for just $5.
So just visit forhims.com/asaphair, the website is super sleek.
We'll see you next week for a new science video.